this is Android tool time Google IO
Edition where we announce a preview of
the new Android studio 3.0 now available
for download in the cannery channel we
decided to bump the major version to 300
thanks to the many new features and some
breaking changes that we're introducing
in this release we've been listening to
user feedback about adding more language
support to the platform something fun
concise and expressive like Kotlin so
we've decided to bundle Kotlin support
with Android studio 3.0 allowing
developers to immediately start using it
in their apps you can choose to enable
coupling in the new project wizard and
the generated activities will use it by
default or when adding new activities to
your projects you can use the language
selector at the bottom to switch between
languages and finally the convert Java
file to Kotlin file refactoring will
help when converting your existing
classes Android studio 3.0 is based on
the 2017 dot one branch of IntelliJ IDEA
and includes all the enhancements from
this and the previous stable release
including parameter hints for method
calls semantics highlighting smart
conflict resolution and syntax
highlighting in version control and more
to help developers bring Android o
features to their apps we're adding
support for font resources and adaptive
icons in the IDE you can now create and
preview xml and binary fonts in the
fonts resource folder the layout editor
also lets you pick downloadable forms
from the google fonts site for text
views to create an adaptive launcher
icon for your app open the asset studio
and select the foreground and background
images that you'd like to use of course
we're also including all system images
for the Android emulator so you can test
your changes on the current L Developer
Preview build consigning with Android
studio 3.0 there are also big changes in
the build system we have built bytecode
transformations called the sugar into
the default tool chain enabling
developers to use Java 8 language
features in their code and libraries we
support lambdas method references
default and static interface methods and
try with resources on all API levels if
you are previously using
djaq which is now defecated or some
other bytecode rewriter such as retro
lambda migrating is as simple as
removing them from your built files with
the new Gradle plug-in we are bringing
performance enhancements to the build
process such as dependency resolution at
execution time faster builds for
projects with a large number of modules
and incremental taxing to support more
fine grained dependency configuration
including variant awareness for library
modules we had to introduce breaking
changes to our Gradle DSL so please
refer to the documentation for migration
steps to reduce the burden of setting up
and maintaining CI servers we are also
launching Google's maven repo as a place
where we distribute Google's build
artifacts at launch we provide the
Android support libraries and you can
start using them by adding the maven
repo URL to your Gradle files ok let's
talk about some more updates in the IDE
itself for debugging performance
problems with your apps we now ship the
unified Android profiler in studio it's
really a set of three profilers for CPU
memory and network shown on a single
timeline that also includes various
events such as user inputs rotations and
activity changes by clicking on any of
the three profilers you can open the
details view for CPU this includes a
list of threads and a way to record and
explore method traces the memory view
now shows a more detailed breakdown of
where the memory is allocated as well as
lets you track object allocations and
dig into heap dumps the network tab
apart from showing network's activity on
a graph includes request and response
information such as headers and payloads
for HTTP requests that were made using
one of the supported clients for now we
support HTTP URL connection and recent
versions of volley and ok HTTP please
note that when trying out the Android
profiler on prio devices and emulators
you have to enable advanced profiling in
the run configuration window in order to
see full information if you're writing C
or C++ code in another IDE or perhaps
you're using other tools such as game
engine toolkit to create our apk you can
now use the Android studio native
debugger with your app open the apk for
debugging at
the debug symbols and sources and you
will be able to step through code just
as with an app developed inside studio
Android studio 300 is the first release
to support creation of instant apps from
your Android project there are two new
module types instant app and feature
together with a new refactoring system
they help modular eyes your app the app
links assistance helps set up the
necessary application ink for running
instant apps if you run into any
problems when testing instant app builds
we've updated the apk analyzer to open
instant up zip bundles but that's not
all the Dex viewer now supports loading
program mapping files to show removed
and retain nodes and can generate
ProGuard keep rules it also has an
improved user interface including
filtering and search lets you explore
method usages inspect byte code
decompile to smiley format and supports
multi decks the layout editor and the
layout inspector are both getting
updates to make iterating on layouts
easier the editor includes better
right-to-left support new constraint
layout features such as change and
barriers and has a new error panel
showing problems in your layouts for
example when you're missing constraints
if you need to pull files from a device
or emulator try out the device File
Explorer a much more user-friendly way
to browse the remote file system than
using ADB for example and finally we
have exciting updates in the Android
emulator for the first time we're
shipping emulator system images which
contain the full Play Store enabling you
to seamlessly test integrations with
other apps without having to sideload
apks placed around the emulator also
means that you no longer have to deal
with outdated Google Play services
libraries which will automatically
update just like on a real Android
device please note that the play
emulator images are signed with release
keys so you won't be able to get
elevated privileges if you require root
access you can use the standard AOSP
emulator builds other important changes
in the emulator includes OpenGL ES 300
compatibility and new bug reporting tool
under emulator help Wi-Fi network
emulation and a proxy settings page for
where developers
rotary input controls whoo as you can
see there are a lot of new things to
play with in this release of Android
studio remember that we're doing these
previews to get your feedback and fix
bugs that you find in your project you
can use the new Android issue tracker to
get in touch with us and be sure to
follow Android studio on Twitter for
updates
[Music]